pilots are missing pilots are missing
come clear come clear pilot to
Bombardier pilot the bomba dear
what is your location pilot the mama
dear
well he nuts or what monday may thirty
it may the power be with you
[ __ ] uncle Joey here reporting
on Memorial Day so Luke the flag grab
your dick and let these [ __ ]
know we ain't stopping for the land of
the free and the home of the brave put
that your [ __ ] pipe to smoke that
[ __ ] the home of the brave you
understand me nothing else no fakeness
no [ __ ] look at me [ __ ] that [ __ ] a
bazooka a bayonet and a [ __ ] Nazi
helmet that's it you go to war
hand-to-hand combat and the doom the
whole [ __ ] deal
have I told you [ __ ] I'd love
smoking reefer on a monday morning it's
a beautiful day to be alive the birds
are chirpin the clouds aren't the sun is
trying to break through and here you are
another fun-filled [ __ ] day to be
with your families and give thanks to
the [ __ ] soldiers who went over there
she'd go to Starbucks and hang out with
your [ __ ] [ __ ] friends with your ads
and talk about this [ __ ] you ain't kind
of [ __ ] do you understand me that all
changes to that every time you see a
soldier you [ __ ] salute that
[ __ ] say you're the man I'm
just visiting [ __ ] and that's it
but Joey what's with the chitter-chatter
you're gonna support that number again
leave we got the canister with no name
manner that means no names no names this
is the [ __ ] that kill [ __ ] hidden
everybody that's it we have a nice
podcast last night we talked about this
we talked about that we had nothing else
going on tomorrow i'm on jr e tonight
i'm at the comedy store hosting the open
mic from seven to ten if you're not
doing nothing and you're like train
wrecks come on down [ __ ] but Joey
what's with the [ __ ] billboard [ __ ]
hit me with some smoke of debt here it
comes
look at that huh now we think my lungs
look like emphysema plus plus plus I got
everything in there I got foot fungus in
my lung I got Jimmy the man I got
everything you understand me I worried
you can't even [ __ ] describe but what
do men do sit on my couch with oxygen
tank huh huh [ __ ] no I'm out there
rolling getting beat up walking around I
don't give a [ __ ] Jack I gotta stop but
who gives a [ __ ] my cardio sucks but I
keep going I'm like the Eveready battery
understand me keep going keep smoking
look at that goes the clouds you
understand me those this [ __ ] me this
is the meal of death kick Utley this is
the mule ready this thing gets you
[ __ ] high even when you don't want to
be high and it doubles as a [ __ ]
weapon you understand me and I poker a
[ __ ] car how many times this pipe is
flowing down not that this is tough as
nails as [ __ ] today but it's Monday but
just this is a holiday that's for
Gentiles you're still writing it goes
down you're still attack an attack
attack attack attack you don't give a
[ __ ] dolly dolly dolly darling only
ultra boy your cordial ally they attack
attack attack Joey what's with the
chitchat let's park another boat why not
why not outside it's Monday what were
you gonna go what are you do not you
ever sit there huh I'm little my friends
house and you cheeseburger you got it
keeps barking baby exactly this is how
the day starts if you're [ __ ] day and
start with the [ __ ] bowl of that
you're slipping you're walking around
Los it's what the problem is yes
something's wrong with me but I don't
know what you need the [ __ ] and hit that
bite that's what you need to do stop
your [ __ ] crime eat now mr. you
[ __ ] [ __ ] friends I don't know what
this I can't snap out of it won't smoke
a bowl of uncle Joey's [ __ ] recipe
and you'll snap out of it understand me
your heart will stop pumping you'll
start hearing Chinese songs dr. dad I
gotta thought that their animals last
time you [ __ ] that was last time you
got stolen her [ __ ] Chinese music
yeah until you don't hear Chinese music
when you stop keep smoking keep hitting
that [ __ ] way
dr. bellezza
how much smoke stays in there he do dr.
police's breathing exercises all that
dead smoke fruit flies are you see
anyone have I told you [ __ ] I'm
stone yes I am cuz i smoke that that's
why I had time to oh this tastes
tremendous I didn't really want to be
that I ever hang out with some of you
tell you that I didn't really want to be
that high really think it's time you
talk to somebody I think I gotta talk to
somebody myself hey we're not problems I
got sorrows boom
we all do but you're [ __ ] settled you
write them down and your move on okay if
not I don't want you walking around like
gloomy Gus I got time for gloomy Gus you
gotta walk around we get decked out like
you own the joint ok if you don't be
gloomy Gus I'll piss on somebody else's
leg today it's monday we gotta start off
with the right state of mind I know him
I'm gonna positive boo go [ __ ] yourself
it's called the right state of mind we
positive thinking to all these [ __ ]
most it was a negative experience and
listener a dick in the ass is a negative
experience if you look at it the wrong
way you understand whatever what I'm
trying to say is it's Monday go out
there and grab the world by the balls
ain't nobody gonna give you dick in the
stem I don't know if it's our that's
holiday for these muckety-mucks like
potato salad with [ __ ] up shirts for
you your savage you're [ __ ] cold
understanding your marine your nepal
you're always on [ __ ] core you kid
anyway we gotta go
I'm stoned to the gills on even know why
I'm out here should be in the house
hiding for myself anyway I love you guys
see you tonight at the comedy store what
tomorrow joe rogan experience across the
board [ __ ] get your [ __ ] together
uncle Joey loves you remember look
around you never know stay black a toy
it didn't come i'ma tella being our book
get booked adulteries in the wire
illegal but I lied I got hella cool Here
I am alright done by tonight the commies
know seven o'clock Tommy's denounced a
black